we've got some breaking news in the
hugely profitable video gaming world
Sony stock is falling right now one and
a third percent after the parent of the
PlayStation pretty much refusing at this
hour to acknowledge it's got major
cross-play problems with the hottest
game on the planet right now fortnight
over the last couple of months Sony have
been under fire for their controversial
policy on cross-platform play industry
icons like Todd Howard have publicly
called Sony unhelpful over full a76
cross-play conversations and a
significant backlash was generated over
Sony's disinterest in enabling cross
play for fortnight this is far from the
first time the games industry and
consumers have argued about cross play
but with publishers and developers
pointing the finger at Sony and the
technical hurdles all but solved if
indeed there ever were any the heat is
now on for Sony to make a call on
whether to enable cross play or
potentially risk a PR nightmare of
alienating their players or is it it's
absolutely true that Sony are on the
backfoot
as far as their image goes right now on
this issue facing the frustrations of
PlayStation owners who are annoyed at
being locked out of their existing
fortnight accounts when trying to play
on Nintendo switch just because Sony
won't play nice with others Microsoft
and Nintendo have been quick to say
they're happy to jump on the cross-play
bandwagon and it's all up to Sony to
give the green light so given the
continuous up role you'd be forgiven for
assuming it's just a matter of time
until Sony cave but there's a few very
good reasons why they most likely won't
some are more obvious than others so
let's start with the one you're probably
already guessing money
earlier this month Sony Interactive
president and CEO Shawn Layden told Eero
gamer we're hearing the concerns about
our cross play policy we're looking at a
lot of possibilities you can imagine
that the circumstances around that
affect a lot more than just one game I'm
confident we'll get to a solution which
will be understood and accepted by our
gaming community while at the same time
supporting our business if you feel like
those were a lot of words that don't
really say anything you're at about the
same place I am
Vegh lip service plays into Sony's best
interest right now because no publisher
wants to say no we're not implementing
cross play fortunately we have insiders
like former Sony developer John Smedley
who tweeted last month when I was at
Sony the stated reason internally for
the cross play policy was money they
didn't like someone buying something on
an Xbox and being used on a PlayStation
simple as that dumb reason but there it
is well it's actually not a dumb reason
it's an aggravating and consumer
unfriendly reason but it is a smart
business reason for sony sony currently
hold the majority market share of the
current console generation by the last
official count in april of this year
79 million ps4 have been sold since
launch in November of 2013 Microsoft
introduced omits have placed Xbox one
sales to date at somewhere between 30
and 50 million units according to data
tracking figures from the NPD group the
ps4 routinely out sells the Xbox one in
North America it may sound trivial but
PlayStation greatly benefits from having
the majority market share without
enabling cross play as it's more likely
those looking to play online together
will pick up the same console as their
friends based on those previous figures
the odds are two to one that your
friends have ps4 and not Xbox ones so
you're more likely to pick up a ps4 if
playing online together is a big factor
in your console purchase decision this
works out great for Sony and conceding
their strong financial position by
making the play a friendly choice in
enabling cross-platform play just isn't
sensible for them we got in touch with
Microsoft to get the official word on
that Cross place dance and they told us
at Microsoft
our vision is to deliver the games you
want to play across the devices you want
to play on connecting you to the people
you want to play with to ensure we're
always providing more value and choice
whether that means working with our
partners to deliver cross network play
with games like rocket League and
fortnight or enabling cross device play
with the likes of minecraft we are
supportive of new scenarios that enable
more people to play and have fun
together while gaming Nintendo's
official line delivered in a 78
shareholders meeting is pretty similar
nintendo senior executive officer Susumu
tanaka stated cross-play basically comes
about from conversations between
publishers and platform holders
we are inclined to do what we can to
help publishers incorporate cross play
when that is what they want the other
parties involved also have a say in
whether we're able to reach this outcome
or not so we will continue to discuss it
with them cross play is also useful in
sustaining the longevity of games with
smaller player bases as you'd expect
games with massive player bases benefit
to most stories that cover cross play
conversations typically paint Microsoft
as the inclusive hero with success
stories like Minecraft which is playable
on all platforms
except for Sony's while Sony is
typically depicted as the kid in the
corner who won't share any of their toys
well I'm not arguing this is an accurate
depiction I do think there's a larger
story to be told here and to get into
that we need to take a look at last
generation cast your mind back to 2006
when ps3 sales significantly lagged
behind those of the Xbox 360 at launch
it took a console redesign price cuts
and some massive exclusive games to make
up that gap this was during the same
generation that the we surged ahead
selling over 100 million consoles
worldwide cross-play wasn't as big of a
draw at that time that we had minimal
online infrastructure and Nintendo's
consoles had generally been considered
closed platforms even though the ps3 and
xbox360 marked the beginning of internet
ready consoles different console
infrastructures still dominated
conversations about cross play though
Sony had already introduced online play
between the ps2 and PC for Final Fantasy
11 and Microsoft developed games for
Windows Live in part to facilitate
cross-platform play for the PC the sale
was divided between the ps3 and the Xbox
360 was slim enough that you could
assume there was no compelling internal
push from either company to want to
share player basis 2018 on the other
hand is a very different story and
Nintendo and Microsoft both want a piece
of Sony's playerbase pie last year
Nintendo said they would support
cross-platform play between PC and Xbox
one versions of both rocket League and
minecraft on switch and that's exactly
what they did
although sony has remained holdout
Microsoft are all too happy to publicly
call out Sony for not playing ball with
Xbox bus 4
spencer making statements like the
following to Business Insider I just get
stuck in who this is helping it doesn't
help the developer the developer just
wants more people to play their game it
doesn't help the player the players just
want to play with their friends who also
play games on console that said it may
not be the PR drama for Sony that it
appears to be
we spoke to Wedbush Securities analyst
Michael Pachter who said nobody has ever
purchased a console with the expectation
that they could play multiplayer games
with friends who owned a different brand
of console so it's more remarkable that
Microsoft announced it will allow
cross-platform play and completely
unsurprising that Sony is not playing
along in sony's view they're ahead and
want to stay there they believe they're
on the right path and anything that
helps Microsoft sell consoles
potentially hurts sony sony has been
forced to batten down the pr hatches
while anger over fortnight accounts
rises to the top of news and social
media sites when developers of rocket
league or fallout 76 come out and say
there's no problem on Microsoft's end
and again when epic accidentally enables
cross console play between Xbox one and
ps4 for fortnight proving not only can
it be done but it's evidently super
simple Microsoft and Nintendo have
seized the opportunity to gang up on
Sony but I'm gonna bet neither of them
would be too keen on playing nice if
they had the majority of the console
market either
[Music]
Cerny appears to be banking on the
assumption that it's just a vocal
minority who is upset about their cross
play stance and that the negative
headlines will be swept under the rug by
tomorrow's news with time we'll see
whether that's the case or not but
regardless there's a real danger in how
long Sony can spend allowing this anti
consumer image to fester this sentiment
is shared by pacta who told us Sony's
gamble here is that nobody really
expects them to allow it now and that
this angst will fade away in the event
that they conclude that their refusal to
allow cross-platform plays costing them
overall sales they will relent this is
similar to when Microsoft miscalculated
in 2013 with owner strm plans and
consumers voted vociferously and with
their wallets if Sony hears a loud
pushback or see sales suffer they'll
change their position that said he
ultimately predicted that the cross
console play uproar will blow over and
the Sony won't change their stance they
may have won this generation but with
cross play and backward compatibility
becoming bigger parts of the
conversation regarding what players want
Sony could put themselves in a pause
situation if they ignore these issues
heading towards the next generation of
consoles in a perfect world publishers
would be selling consoles because of the
strength of their hardware their
software libraries and their online
systems and cross-play will be seen as
something that's universally good for
everybody
Sony is now stuck between their apparent
unwillingness to concede their market
share and the danger in establishing an
anti consumer reputation Microsoft have
proven they can turn things around given
their pivot this generation after a few
stumbles and right now they're in a
great position to alienate their main
competitor from players Sony has some
wiggle room to take advantage of their
comfortable position on top and the fact
that their cross play policy is more of
an annoyance than it is a boycott risk
at the moment but if they don't prove
they're willing to play nice at some
point during the tail end of this
generation they risk watching
disgruntled ps4 players think twice when
the PS 5 arrives personally I think it's
far more likely we'll see a late
generation pivot from Sony as opposed to
any real change at this point but let me
know what you think how important is
cross play to you and how will what's
happening right now affect what console
you pick up next generation